baby let's do it riffing with griffin
is this your first podcast from your new
spot yeah it is
wow yes want to give everybody your
address too
hey shut up uh 1326
west nile virus
the music is going on you don't got your
headphones on ladies and gentlemen
welcome to your favorite podcast
that's right baby it with griffin
yeah you know we're not even going to do
the music just [ __ ] he's not
even
riffing with griffin yeah
you know i got baby pipes
all right welcome to the podcast uh long
time friend i'm not gonna take i'm
taking mine off yeah
i don't need to have it on right here my
hair i didn't do my her um
welcome uh first time to the new roof
studio location even though it looks
exactly the same uh
same brick wall baby i'm gonna change it
mr andrew santino welcome buddy
how you doing how are you i'm good i
think this looks good i uh
it only took me two or three hours to
get over here to this side of the
catalina island
it's the same lives on catalina island
it's the same thing when i go over to
where you live
for me bro you act like you're the
center of the universe
go into your you know west of the 405 is
forever
crossing that say same thing on either
side no
it's not what's up baby boy great to be
back great to be here in the new studio
you guys griff's new place is beautiful
it's incredible thank you
uh if you follow me on twitter i will
post his address later today
just so everybody can storm the castle
and find out where he lives speaking of
storming the castle
your boys are getting impeached hey
we're fighting back
hey man you know i had a tough time um
every i had a tough time getting back to
la because you know of course you know i
was at the capitol i was in there
and we have some good stuff also i'm
going to be posting on my patreon
we're selling nancy pelosi's uh [ __ ]
some stuff
from her office yeah yeah yeah yeah her
stress reliever her stress ball we're
selling that
no dude honestly when i when i saw that
i did i was like civil war is gonna
break out
i thought for sure we would have war on
the streets i was like this is about to
be a civil war
no but it's like you know what's funny
about that and it just shows
it really does show the difference in
like how we look at things
in terms of race and economics because
you know there were like so there was no
thought
there'd be a civil war when you know
hundreds of thousands of people are out
in the streets peacefully protesting for
black lives matter
when like you know sephoras are being
burned down and foot lockers are being
looted and all the stuff that was going
on yeah
it wasn't even a thought over at civil
war but the moment some white people
do some stuff all of a sudden now we're
like
this is it
i don't know we'll see it could be the
catalyst these people who've been living
since mcvay whatever the dude they blew
up yeah yeah
those type of people have been around
forever yeah that's the nature of the
company
they just come out of the woodwork every
few years they're like cicadas you know
cicadas they live underground for like
right right right right ten years
just to piss you off for three that's
all it was i mean it's to me it's just
like this is just
it's the nature of having a free society
is that you're going to have people who
want to rebel and you have those people
and we allow them to be who they are
that's the whole idea of free speech and
all this kind of well what do you think
then trump's getting banned from twitter
you think
by the way he's not he's by the way he's
not my boy now you say that everyone's
gonna be like
i have people sometimes that are like
you're a true hardcore trump fan and i
have to play into it for the comedy be
like you you betcha bud
you're about to check it out but check
this out because he got banned from
twitter if you got a call that he wants
to come on uh whiskey ginger your ass
would have them on
yeah i know i know we all would
everybody would have no i was going to
tweet i was going to tweet the other day
but i i
but i decided not to because i didn't
feel like dealing with the with the
nonsense of it but i was going to be
like you guys can say whatever you want
you're gonna miss him on here
he was an energy he was beyond
entertaining on twitter every everybody
you know followed him
everybody you know followed him you hate
him so much stopped by why'd you follow
him it's like
or at least are you gonna follow joe joe
biden on twitter
maybe no that's my point no you're not
no everybody that was like yo trump
sucks [ __ ] trump
they all followed him so so who are you
then so what's the true thing
you want to watch the accident or you
want to watch everything
smooth say i think it's look in my
opinion
the banning trump from twitter thing is
as much as people hate him i understand
but it's an infringement on free speech
he should be able to say whatever
nonsense he wants on there because
who are we trusting to say that he's
saying facts anyway what's the
difference i don't understand well if
you can say some dumb [ __ ] and people
could take your your fans could take it
as
fact yeah but i only the only thing i
disagree with you on
is okay so one um
[Music]
it's a private company and they have
they reserve the right to put whoever
they want they have their list of
sure we can yeah they have they have
their list of things you can't say this
and if you say this you'll get removed
right so it's like did he say one of
those things
you know what it's their thing but
that's like like sizzler can tell me i
can't come in because i don't got shoes
on or whatever their thing is
sure yeah so it's like it's like what
i'm saying is he's
he got a he has a room in his house that
he can go talk to the press
yeah okay so yeah but he loves twitter i
know i know
what he lost was the convenience of
reaching millions of people like this
okay but that's not he didn't lose his
freedom of speech the money
could go down to the post office and
stand in front of it and some news press
can come and he could be like hey this
is what i have to say
but if it starts there where does it end
that's my point right it's the same way
of saying like
it's a slippery slope i i can't stand
the dude but i'm fascinated with just
like everybody else's
but i do think that unless you're in
literally inciting
war and violence unless you're saying go
out and hurt and kill which
that's illegal right if you're not doing
that and you're just saying you're
the chaos of what you're saying because
there's people saying crazy [ __ ] on
there all the time
yeah they've just chosen to censor him
because of the political affiliations
that are assigned to twitter that's just
a fact of the media well there's also a
difference between
just a regular joe sings and someone
like him and someone like him i mean
anybody in a position of power and
authority has a different influence on
people so
that means that their power is silencing
his power yeah no but
that's what i'm saying it's all i don't
think there's being i don't think
there's being silence so much as like
look
the forefathers didn't understand that
there was going to be the internet when
they were writing the constitution
yeah they didn't know that guns were
going to be able to kill people in 100
people in three seconds
yeah they didn't know all these things
when they came up with these rules and
laws and you know
it is what it is but even with the first
amendment people i don't think people
actually know what the
the the the first amendment even says
you know it's like you you cannot
like like the one they use all the time
is you can't yell fire in a movie
theater because if people start
trampling everybody because of your
words inciting yeah you're inciting
okay so like like he clearly was fanning
the flames
regardless if he didn't yeah of someone
savvy and smart isn't gonna go storm the
capital and kill five
no he he
unwittingly didn't realize it was going
to be like that no i don't think he knew
he was going to be like that either yeah
i don't think he i think he was like oh
[ __ ]
you know what i mean yeah and he was
just kind of like oh damn i don't feel
bad for the guy
my point is i just don't know it just to
me it's like a weird little
a little tiny hole in what seems to be
the future of
everything of like we're all going to
start having more checkdowns on
what you can say and what you can't say
and although i don't like the guy
i also i'm like well i don't know if
banning him on twitter is the answer i
don't know well i think you're talking
about a bigger question
and the bigger question is should social
media fall under some sort of government
jurisdiction
no this is the no but but that's what
you are saying though yeah because i
don't want government in more of that i
know but but that's what you're saying
when you're telling when you're saying
that
he shouldn't be banned and it's free
speech well that makes it tied to like
some sort of like
you know it's it's you know you should
be banned if you violate their laws
that's my point so i'm saying if he did
which i'm not privy to if he did
okay that's fine if you violated the
laws that they've already set up to say
you can't do this and this and he did
that
then i get it but i'm saying it's been
so unclear and everyone i talked to was
like i don't really know
so that's my problem is like to me it
should be more clear of like oh this is
what happened this is why we banned it
well i think they're banning them for
the result not for
i know but that's my that's my inherent
issue right then then we should if we
have rules consequences matter
they do but we have to know why we got
there like i i have to
you have to show your work yeah you
can't just go it's because i feel that i
don't think you do
i think you can when it's your private
company like you like
when i come to your house and they can
start doing that to people that's my
point they can start doing that to
people that didn't buy
the laws check this out yeah they can
yeah see that's [ __ ] up i know but
it's a private company see we're acting
like twitter's are right
we're acting like twitter's like no
social security number no [ __ ]
no you don't have
you know i know they are but get off
twitter but you know but you know that
that to me is again the slippery slope
of where then when it starts
how does this all end well the point is
what else can what else can start to
take the same route well i'm glad it
happened there's restaurants that are
like i don't like griff's political
views
i don't you can't eat here anymore you
know what like imagine if that becomes a
reality i'm not saying it is i'm just
saying
i feel like this this gets really
slippery you know what that was a
reality in this country
because there was a time that i couldn't
go into a restaurant i know i miss those
days
people are going to be feeling this is
going to be called like right wing
[Laughter]
no but i'm saying it's like so i know
this has already been like this is
already this is my
this is what i find so can i tell you
something i was talking about this on
my last podcast too because i was just
so angry about this stuff is because
it's funny to me how when it was black
lives matter
how many white actors comics
entertainers
had so much to say not me yeah they had
a lot to say man i didn't say
you know what i'm talking about of
course i made fun of all those people
you know they had to like have their
like
posts up because they didn't want to
come across as racist and then this
happens
and it's people that look like them now
these [ __ ] got nothing to say i
know you know they got nothing to say
everybody's quiet now
everybody doesn't have their political
stance all the all the progressive
liberal comics who
who run their [ __ ] mouth all the time
because they're all liars that's all
it's optimistic now what
now talk about your white guys now right
it's just optics for them they just want
to look i know people don't want to look
like they're on the right side of
something but but
they want to look when they they want to
look when they're on the right side of
something but now
here's an issue where it's like this is
like
it is unquestioned that if
those people have been black brown died
storming the capital
it wouldn't be they shot them it
wouldn't be the other side that had the
mo
more deaths you know what i mean no no
they would have shot every single one of
them you know someone even
it would have been afterthoughts so when
you look at that and you go what has
happened since
they were they were showing these people
out of the capitol like they were
getting off a car
holding
don't leave anything behind you know i
was like come on man so this
so there is different justice for
different people so but anyways let's
not i digress we don't want to go into
like i know we already have yeah we
already have but it's no but
the point is let's get back to twitter
yeah i'm just telling you i understand
you see
it's private and they have every right
to kick the dude off i get it
i totally get it i just think it to me
as someone who you know starts to look
at things like this from a broader scope
and i go
is this going to lead into other things
because we never really knew this is my
problem it's just the ignorance of
social media we don't really know the
power of it so i'm not defending the
idea of trump being on twitter i
couldn't care less i'm defending the
idea of like
well where does this lead us for the
future of social media because truly
it's damaging as [ __ ] it's already super
damaging
you know documentaries and yeah it's
crazy what it does
so my point is i don't give a [ __ ] about
trump
i just look at it and i go uh is this a
crack in the damn does this show
more things about our culture because
look i'm sure i talked about this last
night at dinner
i'm sure zuckerberg in its infancy
created facebook
as a genuine social network to have
young people to find people to drink
with and hook up
and hang out with i'm sure of it who's
hot or not i mean truthfully that's
really what it was right because i was
one of the first generations on it
i went to arizona state we were one of
like the top 15 schools that got to log
in first you know how they did like
yeah it was ivy league and then when it
got opened up it was only like a section
of schools as it went on
i remember we were on there early and i
remember being like yo this is genius
you can just start to like
know your community of people around
yeah they had to test drive it at the
[ __ ] schools
yeah well they put in the ivy league
first and then they went down to dog
[ __ ]
because then you know what the middle
looks like yeah you have to go best and
worse
and then you're like well i understand
the rest let's go to arizona state
[Laughter]
they went they went harvard to herpes
they were like we just want to see the
scale
but they did but but truthfully i
remember the beauty of how simple it was
but now
that dude's a criminal that dude that
dude that dude got caught being the
reality was
he he wanted a pup he was he wanted to
become this evil social puppeteer master
and sell off your whole life and you're
like i'm sure at the beginning he didn't
feel that way but a man that's my point
where does the rest of this go i know
but imagine
here's the thing imagine how powerful
those companies feel right now oh when
they can go
they can shut down the president yeah
that's my point that's scary oh they go
so no no but no
it's great but it's also [ __ ] we have
given them
the power yeah because young people
think
that like i said you get issued a social
security number and a twitter account
yeah it's one of those that's what they
think yeah they think that that [ __ ] is
in government run
no okay so it's like a private company
that we've given an enormous amount of
power and
influence even though almost nobody is
on it that's the other irony
right isn't it like less than three
percent of the world's population is on
twitter but it feels like it's
but it's but i feel like it feels like
it's i feel like all of them combined
you know just you know you think you i i
look at all of them together so it's
like facebook
instagram yeah yeah yeah yeah they're
all together dude they're yeah
i know they're all one thing and they're
so they're gonna take and they're gonna
take us the [ __ ] out
that's what's gonna happen yeah so it's
like i just go you want to you want to
so i
i just take offense to when people say
that his freedom of speech was getting
taken away because i'm like no it hasn't
no they didn't take away convenience was
taken away that's it but i do think that
is a
it's an infringement on
to me it's like an infringement to me
it's like uh
it's it's not creating a narrative where
you can have more than one person now
he is a he is the broad example of the
extreme
but like to me it just shows me that the
future may be
well if you don't agree with that the
typical narrative of this social media
site we are going to kick you off
i'm saying i'm saying at a smaller level
not trump i'm saying like
it just to me it's a window into a thing
where they go oh griff tends to be more
of a centrist
well this is a pretty liberal site so we
don't want you on here that's why i
tweeted the other day
that's my fear about that stuff it's
like that's weird i tweeted the other
day that
you are and you are right-leaning for
sure so social media everybody knows
griff is a republican social media
should be called an echo chamber now it
is that's all that's all good
yeah it is it's going to it's church you
know it's just an echo chamber for
people to like hear their own thoughts
but my the the to me to go further from
what you're saying is the thing that's
really dangerous about it is
like trump saying well i'm going to
start my own thing
and then then we're not going to know
what those people are talking about and
saying because we're not going to follow
that
and then all the liberals and all the
progressives are going to be like well
we have our own sites and we're going to
get our news that's the danger and
that's the real danger so that's
basically what i'm talking about yeah
yeah yeah he's like one that
essentially after all this 15-20 minutes
of talking about this the truth really
is i'm not concerned for trump
i don't think he they stole anything
from him i just think it's a window into
what could be our future the division of
the country even more
yeah it's a small step in something that
could be bigger now granted i don't feel
bad for the dude i don't really give a
[ __ ] but also
i go if it becomes only our news versus
only your news
we're in bad shape yeah i agree that
gets scarier so i'm glad i'm actually
glad that they did it because maybe
it'll shake people up for them to
realize oh this is just a private
company
yeah that they have their own agenda see
people forget like when you look at say
google for instance right
we get all our information from google a
lot of people didn't store it right but
we forget that this is a private company
yeah but you have to realize when you
search for something and the first 15
responses are like
add add add add ad and oh here is here's
the dick enlargement
[Laughter]
damn i had to go through all this and
get to the thing i'm looking for so it's
like we forget that like no
they have all this power and influence
and it's just for money
so like maybe it's good that we go oh
wow you mean they can kick the pr
because i'm sure there are people out
there that thought you can't kick the
president off twitter
and i'm like yeah you can yeah there's
no people that surprise me there's
people that own it you know so it's like
whatever
let's talk about other [ __ ] because like
i haven't seen you in so long and it is
good to see you
you know the other day we got this sad
news about jeff scott you know
yeah and i went live listen i was i've
been doing my podcast the night before i
release it now just so i can like get
everything in that i want to get for the
week and it's
i feel like it's fresh but i couldn't do
it i got the news from bobby he called
me
and i don't know why but i immediately
broke down into tears like i don't
i didn't know jeff that well but i've
known him for 10 years yeah me too you
know what i mean
so and that really hit me hard because
it just made me realize like oh there's
people i'm never going to see again
this is so strange you know that's the
exact same words that came out of my
mouth
you know because it was people i go i
take for granted it's like there's that
person that
we just saw every day and we just go oh
hey what you call it
you know it's like you know and i go and
then and he was the kind of person you'd
have
nice conversations with or just i didn't
know what it was but it hit me so i
couldn't do my podcast
so the next day it was monday that i'm
releasing it i go let me go live
i'm just going to do it live man i was
so emotional
couldn't do it i i did but i was like
[ __ ] blubbering like a
you know you know during a grown man
with his emotions
[Laughter]
ain't no [ __ ] yeah i was blubbering and
stuff so
anyway my point is it's like i really it
made me
feel like
like who are my friends who should i
keep in touch with
and not just your close loved ones right
it made me realize that there's a other
layer of people in my life
that i should probably reach out to and
make sure they're okay too
just to stay connected even with like a
personal community to me
community to me like the comedy store
yeah so like we talk we talk all the
time yeah because you're one of my best
friends yeah
but it's like if we think about it we're
in that hallway with who
like sandy danto how's he doing with uh
you know
even some crazy like boom shakalaka is
boom okay
is this [ __ ] alive you know what
i mean like it's like and i go like when
am i gonna see
like all of these you know eleanor
kerrigan what am i gonna see you know
there's so many of these
comics and people at the store that i go
man and you realize too it's just hard
also
but i don't know i think the the the
everything that with covet and the
pandemic and being at home all the time
and all this stuff
it made me start to think about all
these things how is it making you feel
like you know with
well that was i mean it just you know
yeah the door was just closed and seeing
all these people that were in your life
all the time and unless they talk like
you and i talked but i only talked to
about you know five
five people from the store that i keep
in contact with all the time
and so it's kind of it's just we it's
just it's hard and weird
and i had a moment where i was you know
i was
i just not broke down crying but i broke
down mentally
and i was like i just admitted it out
loud finally i was like i'm depressed
this this i'm
[ __ ] depressed it got me depressed
i'm so sick of not being able to go to
the club i'm so sick of not being able
to feel free to like
try new [ __ ] and um and then i was at
the i was in my hotel
in san jose i had to go to san jose to
shoot this thing yo this is crazy
oh the only [ __ ] people in the hotel
really it's like 155 rooms literally the
guy at the front desk was like
it's just you so you should feel safe i
was like this is crazy sorry because i
had to go to the shoot shoot this little
thing right then what the towels no
yeah yeah but he goes we don't and we
don't do
they did they do full sanitization of
every room and then this
the um the cleaning service only comes
when the guests are
gone for a day so you leave and they
don't even come clean that day
do they wait another day just for the
idea of maybe
whatever i don't even know what that
what is that but anyway i was
i woke up to drive back down to l.a and
um
i was talking to rogan and talking to e
getting a bunch of people about jeff
because i had seen my phone one off in
the middle of the night
and um and i said the exact same thing
dude that's crazy that i literally
verbatim
i just started getting tears in my eyes
and i was like it's just not fair that i
don't get to see somebody ever again
yeah it's not fair that you just like oh
now i don't get to see you again
yeah yeah but that bummed me out a lot
and then i had to sit in the car for
four and a half hours thinking about it
which will [ __ ] you up by the way just
because you're like sitting there kind
of numb in a car and it's just
headed down the five it's there's
nothing but fields and you're just
looping in your head
all the scenarios
can we pee again i need to pee again you
peed five times it's [ __ ] 200 miles
no but she you know i just was looping
in my head she passed out and i just had
my own thoughts to sit with so i just
thought about it a lot a lot a lot and
look i i can't even pretend like jeff
and i were super close because we were
not we were we were friendly as [ __ ]
there and he
i loved him and he showed love to me and
it was wonderful but like the things
that bummed me out were like
just the simple stuff about jeff that
i'll be like oh man like
you know i remember if i was trying out
new [ __ ] late and it wasn't going well
he would sit at the piano and just sit
there and laugh
yeah yeah yeah if you if he knew you
were trying a bunch of he would always
sit by the piano for the first like
couple of minutes
after he went on and if he saw that you
were doing old [ __ ]
he'd get up pretty fast this is for me
personally because
he'd be like he's doing great he's
already you know it's almost like a
parent making sure you're okay as weird
as that was
and then when he saw i was doing a bunch
of new [ __ ] or if he could tell i was
like
you know really [ __ ] experimenting he
would wait
and sit there for a lot longer and i
think he would laugh really loud he had
this boisterous laugh
and i think that was his that was a
trick he was
you know being like i'm gonna give you a
little bit of a boost whether or not the
audience knows it or you know
it but he used to do that stuff and i
really appreciated the [ __ ] out of that
he also used to call me [ __ ] all the time
which i thought was
i love that he's like shut up he was
just truthful you know what i mean cuz
you know who yeah he knows where i
really am
no i used to like that he would uh i
used to like that like
he was either right on time to get you
off stage or he was an hour and a half
later or he would be like whatever
he used to get how many nights that you
and i would go before or after each
other
and he wouldn't be there i'd be like god
damn it jeff
then he would just come in the door you
know whatever because i never had to ask
who's next if it was me and you we know
we're there we saw each other yeah
whatever but it was always like you're
gonna come up to no music so i try to
stall
you know what i mean so you're like i
hope he can be there because it's hard
to come up to no music there's
there is something about the feeling
that transition is really tough it's one
of the toughest things in common
so hard because the audience is like we
just loved what you did yeah so i feel
like you're going to love this next guy
unless there's an emotional like um
vibe to it it's almost like clap clap
clap and then silence is like
hey the music helped so much
yeah i was thinking about that um two
nights ago when i was in the hotel too
of like
who's going to be able to do that
[ __ ] thing who's going to be the new
person that does you take it for granted
dude you totally take it for granted and
also it's
also too it's a terrible job who would
want it it's it's it's but you have to
be there at what like
six or seven for the one of the one of
the mike's
start whatever it is and then he's got
to go till two nobody in the morning
and a person that like he was just a
part of the comedy story he'd been there
for so long he was from the old guard
was there everything there was mitzi he
was there all the time 25 years
yeah it became his thing you know it's
like he came he came to l.a because he
thought he was going to die
you know what i mean yeah you know and
then that's a story that a lot of people
don't know yeah he can't you know and so
he and then he just he lived he lived a
good life you know what i mean
oh my god you know so it's like but
anyways
he became a symbol for me of
loss yeah you know he became a symbol of
like
those good people in your life that you
may never see again
yeah no i know that yeah there's a lot
of people that could die at the comedy
story and i'd be like all right
i'd be like dude who
like that guy's gone i guess that's
that's sad no yeah but just so you know
this i hear something off subject but on
subject
you say you're staying at a hotel yeah
so i have a fantasy football group which
by the way i'm not allowed to talk about
it technically they were like you can't
travel in california 120 miles
oh well you just did yeah i'm back
but i got tested i have the antibodies
too so i have i want to talk about that
too you have haven't coveted so i had um
anyway i've been in this same fantasy
football group for like 20 years now
right
so you know we have school buddies and
[ __ ] uh not really okay you know i'm
long-term friends yeah long-term friends
so anyways one of them sends a picture
of
he goes i was in a hotel with my
daughter and my family and my daughter
found this
in a in a in one of the drawers
oh yeah and it was like a needle like a
heroin needle
it wasn't it was like like some sort of
medication for like a bad disease oh
just a hypodermic needle whatever it was
just in the future
yeah yeah yeah yeah and i was like my
first thought was like dude what days in
are you staying at
like that's on you what motel five are
you at yeah
or just motel are you staying there
but i thought to myself damn people are
so
worried about kovid yeah that they
shirking
all their responsibilities 100 by the
way
his daughter would have fully recovered
if she found a napkin
full of covet right right do you
understand what i'm saying yeah like
his daughter could have found a napkin
just dripping with covid
wiped it all over her face yeah and in
two weeks she would have been fine
okay for the most part according to the
numbers it's less than
one percent yeah okay so we think right
yeah but like
if it was a aids medication or if it was
like you know
whatever the thing it was something bad
right she could have easily been
you know kids they put [ __ ] in their
mouth you know you know what i mean it's
like so
to me i'm like yo hotel yeah what the
[ __ ] like
you know you you're worried about you're
worried about kovit
and i get it but damn it's that is an
example
of like the paranoia and craziness that
we have
that we're not worried about anything
else like people are still getting
cancer
people are still like they got to go to
the hospital because they broke their
finger
yeah people got to go to like you know
and it's it's as if the only thing that
matters
is covet yeah my buddy's dad just passed
away
and i was like the annoying thing is the
first
thought in everyone's mind is it coveted
is it coveted
i know and it wasn't as if nobody dies
of anything right right and it wasn't it
was not like many of the deaths i've
heard this past year i've
my uncle just passed away um a month ago
and that wasn't coveted either it was
cancer and um
it does get annoying that even your own
[ __ ] brain goes
yeah is it coveted even this thing about
jeff yeah i know
that's the first thought i first thought
i was like oh no he did he get you know
and you go damn well he's a compromised
immune system so that is kind of
that that is there is a parallel right
but right so so to us that's pretty
specific to be like
you have a compromised immune system
when you're living with hiv if you do
get very sick in any way
you can die yeah you know what i mean
given whatever circumstances
but anyway yeah my buddy's father just
passed away
and uh i don't know it just it shook me
up and i was like
not to be like whatever about covet but
it is tragic to think that it's getting
all of our attention and as it should
it's a [ __ ] international pandemic
but there's moments like that where i go
damn dude he probably
just wants to not have covert be a worry
that's happening so he can like
mourn this in in real time you know what
i mean like they have to mourn
not in real time he could they can't see
their other people in the family you
know it's just it's [ __ ] crazy it
sucks
it's like it's like saying like uh you
know like people people but i don't get
to celebrate my birthday this year
yeah shut the [ __ ] up it's like people
don't like if you're if somebody you
love dies you don't get that you don't
get to mourn a death in real time
you have to like wait or do it in
whatever protocol
about this like [ __ ] crazy a friend
of mine's having a baby
and it's like oh everyone is having a
baby right now yeah my buddy just had a
baby you could only have one person in a
room you can't have too many people in
the waiting room
so that's one of those experiences that
like gone yeah that's gone we're not
even thinking about that
you know it's like everything is about
this thing you know i was call i did an
instagram post because
you know because first of all everybody
in the instagram comments thinks they're
an expert on kovit
you know they have so much to say but
everyone on the internet is a genius oh
all
right
of course going to med school so i'm
just trying to get because i
still have questions yeah and i can't
get answers
you know but people will send me
messages like they have the answer and
i'm just like who the [ __ ] are you you
know what i mean
so my thing is like i just want answers
i just want someone to
justify all this from from me well see
but that's a problem nobody knows i can
only tell you what like my doctor told
me
about two different doctors when i got
sick just giving me the course
yeah give me your your experience with
all of that by the way
well i mean you know look i got i talked
i've talked about it a bunch but of
course but this isn't for my
no no no seven people that watch my
podcast there's way more than if you
know that
no well like i love you i'll do it
quickly but like i i a friend of a
friend
told me the tested positive that we had
kicked it with
and so a week later i tested um
i tested uh uh what is it called like
they couldn't read it you know meaning
like
there was signs of the conclusion yeah
inconclusive and i tested two days later
and it was positive
and anyway so we oh for a week a week
for me was like
um did the sex club call you like hey i
called them
i called them
mike stephen kevin alex and billy that
they need to get tested
i was trying to think of that tom cruise
movie but it didn't come to my head
right away
what you know the one way where they're
they're at the like the
was it far and away no uh you know he's
they're in that it's all the sexual
underground stuff no what is that
oh man nicole kidman tom cruise eyes
wide shut
eyes wide shut i was going to make that
reference we should cut to it
so we got the i've shot party i was
there it was fun
oh anyways we all wear masks at all so
like head mask
no so you found out you got it i found
out i've got it and i i had sickness for
a week now my experience is my
experience that's i always have to
preface that because people are always
like see
you didn't it's like yeah i didn't get a
fever which is why i call out this fever
thing whenever i go somewhere and
they're taking temperatures
i roll my eyes because i'm like i'm like
everyone every one of my friends that's
a dog
pony show yeah every one of my friends
that had that have had kovid
not one of my friends had a fever not
one listen so i was saying this fever
thing is like
that's not for checking covet no that's
to make everybody feel optics
yeah it's just like when you take your
shoes off at the airport [ __ ] it's
all the tsa process is absolute nonsense
it's [ __ ] okay it's
nonsense i say it every time they go
you've been randomly screened and i'm
like okay then why do i have
the [ __ ] pre-check why did i pay for
global entry then
how could this be yeah i thought that's
what this was don't even get me started
i know you and i are on the same page
so it's just a dog and pony show people
because because if they really like how
many terrorists do they catch in a year
you know if a million people come
through the lax
tell me like i want to know that they
stopped 20. they catch you know what
they catch people do
um being foolish right all right i
didn't know that knife was 100
it's more like a guy trying to get a gun
in it back home not to be
not because he's going to kill people
it's like yeah i i didn't know i
couldn't carry on my gun it's like well
you're just being foolish you're just
dumb yeah yeah yeah a lot of dumb people
all right
but anyway jumping back so a week for me
was
um a week for me was it was just you
felt like [ __ ] i felt
like [ __ ] it sucked and then the next
week was a recovery week
where because you had to quarantine so
it was kind of just me
um being tired and lazy and i will and i
will say this everyone's experience is
different some people get riddled from
this thing and it is very
i have seen it yeah yeah i know family
and friends that have gotten very very
sick
there's this broad spectrum of yeah you
have no idea what you're gonna get
um but the crazy thing is
what i've come to my own personal
conclusion is the depression and the
anxiety that like some of us have that
pre-exist like myself you know i have
clinical depression
so it's like it's it's intensified
during that time period because
you're scared you don't really know the
uncertainty yeah
you know even though you're with
somebody i'm still you're lonely as [ __ ]
because you're with your own thoughts
and you have to separate so
you're like what if this turns that
becomes this looming fear
then you start to think is people are
going to think is there going to be a
stigma
on you well yeah do you feel like people
come to you like ooh that guy had cove
well yeah i mean i think there was a
stigma i talked about that there was a
stigma there is i mean now
less so because 90 [ __ ] million
people around the world have it but when
i got it in october
or the end of september it was like this
thing where it's like how did you get it
i got phone calls from people i won't
mention their [ __ ] names
but like annoying [ __ ] that i
don't even talk to they don't care about
me as a person right right give a [ __ ]
about me they never talked about me
talk to me and now they're like can you
tell me everything you're like one of
the closest people i know that's gotten
it
and i badly want to be like go [ __ ]
yourself i don't [ __ ] you don't [ __ ]
know me [ __ ] you like you're just
interested because i have something like
it was gross and also their assumption
is like what were you doing it's like
[ __ ] i was doing
what you're doing yeah you're like like
you i was you know i was licking
doorknobs right you know that i know
yeah i was like i was having beers with
a friend like okay so anyway
we recovered thankfully and i the only
thing you can hope now this is the
uncertainty thing that i don't like is
like
well i hope it doesn't have long-term
ramifications right right i don't
[ __ ] know
but at the same time i've come to grips
with it like
drinking for the past 20 years of my
life because i enjoy having some liquor
that's got ramifications so it's like
i can't control much at some point
you're like i don't know
it's you can't sit back and go what if
coveted in 20 years it gives me
it's like well then i'll have to cross
the bridge unfortunately when i get it
in the same way that like you know
you're going to get lung cancer
or you could get lung cancer from
smoking in 20 years there's nothing
almost like you could get like there's a
lot of
you know your own choices you eat
unhealthy foods and
we all have these things that are like
well i can't really [ __ ]
there's nothing i can do but let me ask
you let me ask you this though and it's
like
and to be sensitive about it too because
i don't want to like
like i don't have a opinion on either
side of this i just want to put that out
there
i'm this is why i wanted to have an
expert come on just
so i can just ask questions and get like
a scientific answer but
this is a another kind of thing it's
like you know you're someone that had it
would you consider your would you
consider your experience with kova
that was like mild you know you know
what i mean like in comparison like when
you're here
according to their terms it's called
mild like like whatever the doc whatever
they've laid out online like the cdc has
laid out
like what is called mild or moderate or
extreme and then like i we i cat
we categorized as mild because of our
experience our experience was like
we fit in the mild box now when you go
through something like an experience
like that you went through this mild
thing you had it
and then you see how
how we've um reacted to kovit
in general say even just in california
because we live in california
all the businesses that have shut down
all of the
you know like one-on-one cafe is shut
down which is like i can't even believe
it we used to go there
i know all the time i made fun of it i'm
on my other piano
but it was it was sad but i was like
this is just yeah it's yeah so what i'm
saying though is like
for yourself is there a part of you that
you know because of what you experienced
you go
are we doing the right thing did it made
you did it make you question that
yeah but i questioned it from the
beginning before i even had it but like
here's the problem
you can't control how many people are
going to get it from you so
when they say we're overwhelming the
hospitals right like i i played golf
the other day with his brother-in-law is
the head of infectious disease so he was
pretty candid about everything he should
get him on your podcast
he wouldn't do it he's too rich and too
you know he's got his own life
i mean he's gonna come on somebody if
i'm like i'm on my podcast he's like
[ __ ]
no chance i say one wrong thing yeah
yeah yeah no way or he might if i say
the truth yeah then they'll get
they'll come kill me a red dot on his
head
in your house too like how'd that red
dot where'd that come from
so my wife is like she's a part of it
yeah but
no but i felt that way about so he
this is such a long argument to get into
but like
the way i've always felt about it was
this essential businesses
were deemed essential by whom right
that's my big okay food is literally the
only essential thing if we really wanted
to call these things essential business
it would be food people need food and
that's all they really need
if this was the case and pharmacies yeah
okay okay sure medicine but
medicine at some point we could have
those things delivered to your home
so if you needed to get things and we
couldn't have everyone going into the
store we had to create a delivery
service just for food food would be
literally the only essential business
the [ __ ] weed store up the street
from my house has been open the whole
time okay the whole time
so you're telling me that some woman
that owns some little business boutique
has to close down
but the weed [ __ ] store can stay open
why so
it just comes down to nobody
got control over this fast enough to
make a good economical decision on how
we need to make this
work without just going shut it all down
bro target and best buy are open
they've been open those are those
essential businesses no
it's that they have enough economic
adjustment
and they have enough economic influence
and political that they know
you're going to keep us open the
politicians are like i'm going to keep
the [ __ ] open
yeah it's in political interest in some
degree because look in the restaurant
thing too
everything is state by state right texas
is open a lot of places are okay so my
point is
what i don't get is we live in southern
california we are privileged to have a
different
temperature gauge than most places
you're telling me
it's 77 today 77
i know you can't set up tables 10 15 20
feet apart
and have people outside have have
servers wearing masks gloves
and shields and have them serve plates
of food
just like they're making the food
already for delivery and takeout they're
doing that right now
so you're telling me they can't just
drop it to a table and by the way we
don't know they got masks on at the
restaurant
when they're making our food no [ __ ]
that's my other problem yeah i had a
couple you're just seeing this
[ __ ] hey come out here let me
see that
suit i had a conspiracy at the beginning
that i was like [ __ ] if people are
getting it through food
i was joking about that year months ago
i'd be touching everything too like [ __ ]
these people
yeah have you ever worked have you ever
worked or seen coming from the midwest
in the food industry
um when you go to farms and you see how
farms operate do you you you think
people that are on farms right now are
all abiding by ppe
well first of all you're out of your
[ __ ] bro it's it's at farms
where kovac came from no [ __ ] no so it's
just like
it's when it's them putting chicks and
pigs and chickens in the same place
where do you think this is starting from
no no they said it was the they said it
was the
lab they think it was the lab the wet
market is where it spread but but truth
be told
all i know is if everything is going to
be state by state law
then how come in this state of south of
california particularly in southern
california where our weather is
unbelievably ripe for being outside why
can't these restaurants have people sit
outside
extremely distance make the distance
even further
and i just don't get why they've chosen
specifically certain things are allowed
to be okay because best buy ain't okay
to be open
this is okay this is exactly where i'm
at with you on this
i'm i'm with you on this 100 and the
thing is
you'll get people that will say in
comments and they'll message you know
you know and they keep saying you don't
understand culture okay so overwhelmed
and i go okay first of all overwhelming
the hospitals
and the dangers of covet are not the
same thing right there's a correlation
but they're not they're not the same
yeah they're not working
so like in the beginning of the pandemic
we close we had to close things down
because we didn't know what was gonna
happen
right so they were like let's make sure
we don't overwhelm the hospitals
okay eight months later the hospitals
weren't overwhelmed so then but then we
still were having the same things
so it's as if the people in charge
weren't in coordination with
they were people that know to figure out
like all right here's what we need to do
so we can keep the economy going and
keep people safe yeah
all i'm asking is justify all this just
you know justify
why we just go from we go from like okay
things are open salons are open now
they're closed
you know it's like i just go like lives
are ruined
yeah okay and if you all i'm saying is
and my pet peeve by the way
my pet peeve about that is
those in power and just like these
people on twitter that were caring about
black lives matter these same people
that were
hooping and hollering but have no
relationship to black people or black
culture or really actually invest in any
of that stuff
shop at black businesses they themselves
won't do the same thing
these same people are the same people
that were hooper and holler and stay at
home stay at home stay at home
right they don't take in any
consideration who has the
ability to stay at home bro listen who
has the ability
where are you don't get me started it's
like ellen being like stay at home
you got kovid yeah you got covered what
the [ __ ] are we talking
so you're saying stay at home to poor
people who i got three kids they can't
even afford [ __ ] rent
stay at home means what so stay at home
says stay at home unless of course you
work in an industry that i need stuff
from
unless you're an amazon worker in the
food industry uh
hypocrisy it's [ __ ] so what does
stay at home mean
i just i i'll go even more specific i
get tired of the rich comics
tweeting out about if we just if we had
just done this
yeah yeah you could do that you got
millions of dollars yeah you don't have
to leave the house you don't got to
leave the house yeah
people are working three jobs anyways by
the way stay at home it should be called
don't
go to raves that should have been the
phrase don't go to rage don't do
dangerous things yeah yeah yeah do your
best
we're figuring it the [ __ ] out as we go
well all i'm saying is like i wish that
they would like
some if there was an expert if there was
a scientist if there was like if the cdc
was coming out and saying hey listen
yeah this thing is so dangerous
it is worth
people's lives being ruined financially
because of the long-term effects of this
right if they said that i'd be like oh
okay
wow i get it yeah yeah i would get it
but it's
hard i'm just being real about it it's
hard
to justify when you go
all right and listen any death is bad
okay
any death is bad of course but like the
death rate is
one percent less than one percent it's
gone down yeah the death rate is like at
some and so it's like is that wrong
maybe that number is wrong because
because when you hear about you you want
you you know we got almost 400 million
people in the country
you know if it was like 10 million
deaths if it was
20 million deaths you you'd be like oh
this is like ebola or something like
that
this is some kind of dangerous spreading
thing that's killing people
at an alarming rate right you you know
then you go oh okay i see
you okay we got everybody would be on
board right but i think
the the people the states that are not
on board the people that are like i
don't want to learn mask or the people
that feel like this
they're just going off i don't know
anybody just sick
and everybody that i know that's sick is
good is well is okay now yeah that's how
they feel okay that's just
it's anecdotal to individuals of course
you know what i mean and so like there's
people that would know you and be like
andrew santino's fine right so why am i
so then
and i'm not saying it and that shouldn't
be the way you look at it either
but it is a reality at the same time
it's the reality of like what is going
on so again i reach out to people just
i would because to me this is just about
i think
this isn't about covet it's about bad
organization yeah
that's literally what it is right this
is just poorly run local governments
right right right this is a really
governmental issue of like
but haven't we seen this a million times
yeah i'll give one devil's advocate to
what we're talking about when i look at
it from the other side
because i have friends that work in the
er i have many people that are in the
medical field
they will tell you they are having
exorbitant numbers of people that are
coming in that are very very sick
and people are still dying right yeah
and they are still dying condolences
all these families all ages are dying
too so there is no
the likelihood of dying in a certain age
group is very low that being said it
does happen so we have we care
about these realities and the doctors
have told me
they're so overwhelmed because there's
so many cases so
it's not that oh it doesn't kill that
many people it's more
they have the ability now with with
steroids and with medicines
more so than in march that we're keeping
more people alive so we're keeping more
people away from death because we have
advancements in medicine
so that's that's the positive thing of
time we're getting close to tylenol
covet and flu for 100 you're going to be
right it'll be on the shelf
we're just getting close to that but the
truth is or maybe
the truth is they're saving more people
from dying but that doesn't mean that
it's still not
crunching our health care system because
so many people are coming in very ill
right now so they're saving them so
that's why the hospitals are going
we're st we're this is it's happening
too fast we'll see you know that's
control okay so that's
so that's their argument and that's what
they should talk
more about 100 i agree you know because
because then
because that makes sense to me because
that is scary because it's not that
they're saying
we're throwing out a thousand bodies a
day no they're saying
and by the way we did have a peak day we
did have like three thousand people or
something insane like that
but they're saying we have people in
gift shops
in beds and gift shops because they have
nowhere else to put them in basements
and
all in like rooms they don't belong and
because they just need to tend to sick
well here's well here's the problem that
should stop here's a problem too i
trip i break my arm i need to go to the
hospital can't
and they're like well we can't even put
you because we can't put you near
covet people yeah so they don't even
have because that's see this is what i'm
saying people act like all the other
[ __ ] just stopped
right like people are not getting sick
you can't no that's what's scary little
kids aren't swallowing marbles so what
they're doing
so they're like they're like they don't
know where to put so i get that that's
what their argument is saying stop
moving them in the hospital
right not saying they're worried about
more cova deaths in from the hospital
form they're worried about
they can't treat everything else yeah
these two things can exist you know that
now even as we talked that through
that makes sense to me but that still to
me doesn't justify
that doesn't answer why everything is
shocking why why why why everything is
shut down and all and all the negative
effects of that there's a thousand
people in trader joe's up the street
from my [ __ ] house and i'm like how
is this legit
[ __ ] rachel's telling me about at
target targets
check this out be packed check this out
she gets there yeah one day
and there's a line around the block 100
yeah okay but wait you know what it was
for
it was for some yes one of a kind
no no no they were in line around the
block for the starbucks
because there was some one-of-a-kind mug
that they were selling that day yeah
this is my point so it was like what
right right so so
so so you know so amber that owns an
antique shop on [ __ ] venice boulevard
she's gotta close and she probably gets
two people in that [ __ ] a day
yeah right at the best of times right
when she's on when she's killing it at
the best of times she needed to close
that [ __ ] down right so that
doesn't make any sense
so that doesn't make sense there's a
vacuum repair store next to my old house
right next to my my old place and i was
like
first of all anybody getting a vacuum
repair wait bro we on the same [ __ ]
page
how many times i pass the store and i go
who's going in there
what's going into this like lamps uh
nobody
nobody but also let them stay open
because ain't nobody going in that [ __ ]
that's not that's not where kovit's
coming from and by the way anybody in
the medical field will tell you all my
friends that are
medical field told me this new surge
isn't from when things were open in
september october and november
it's because people went and saw their
families and friends over the holidays
we had the lowest travel we've ever had
was one third of the normal travel
but the truth is people are sick again
because families got together for the
holidays i'm not saying they shouldn't
if i'm just saying
that's why it ain't because people are
going eating lunch outside in a park
near other people
no it's because people gathered with
their [ __ ] families all right well
let me ask you about this which is the
risk they wanted to take and that's
[ __ ] that's how it goes
so my parents just got the vaccine oh
that's dope yeah you know wait are they
in
spain no they're in no no they're back
they're here they've been here no no
they're in uh
oh they're here now they're in they're
in the california okay yeah you know my
mom's got dementia you know so they they
got the
vaccine the first round of it you know
but
like
i you haven't seen her right i have oh
you have okay yeah
so i i um i'm i'm gonna take the vaccine
when my time comes
you know i don't i don't have no problem
with it but i did take a little pause
when i read all these articles about
like 50 of medical workers don't want to
take it right well there's reasons for
that
yeah this is i know but if you go to a
restaurant
and everybody at the restaurant is like
yeah i'm not eating the soup today you
you go
what the [ __ ] wrong with you because
y'all are experts at this restaurant
right and they're like soup's good for
you though
it's like i but here's my pushback okay
so like the medical people are like
it was political you vaccines don't come
out this fast
my pushback on them is the entire planet
is being affected by this
i am not surprised that the entire
scientific
community was like let's do this they
put everything on the back burner it was
like but you know also let's do this
you know yeah that's that's my other
thing is like this was a business
this is a business there they've been
pfizer's a business
they're not like we're trying to help
people they're like we're trying to pump
his money so
so so i'm not saying it's a conspiracy
i'm saying
their best interest financially was to
get this right that's my point when
somebody's like how so fast you're like
what
this is how they make [ __ ] money
which i by the way why do you think the
nba set up the bubble you know they did
that in record time they're like
everybody get the [ __ ] to disney world
and don't move
we ain't losing nine billion dollars
this year you know what i mean like
you can't at some point people are gonna
sacrifice everything to make the
business
and thank god everyone in every [ __ ]
pharmaceutical company was like throwing
their
hat in the ring because then it just
made it more available so i i i'm not
scared of it and
when that my antibodies are gone i'm
gonna take it too so the i
as soon as i can i'm gonna take it yeah
so i felt like all right that makes
sense to me i mean i just
i have a problem like maybe this is like
my more liberal progressive side of
myself
um i have a problem with
with finding financial profit
healthcare for profit i just i just have
a problem with that
fundamentally as a human being yeah
because i feel like
as a scientist i would like to think
this is me just being uh
whatever the word is but i
would like to think that somebody got
into science because they wanted to
better mankind
like they wanted to discover things like
some it's like yeah right i would but
see
i don't i don't want to think like that
yeah i would like to think that like
somebody goes i want to cure cancer
because i want to
make the world better not ooh if i come
up with a cure for cancer i'm going to
make a billion dollars
like like i would i think that's most
people like i talked about this thing on
my last podcast but you know
i have a guest now so it's great and i
love you know me and i you and i go at
it about these kinds of things so i love
it so i saw on a forum it wasn't a
forbes list but it was one of those 50
richest people in america
yes and one of them was this guy he's
got worth he's worth 11 billion dollars
and he owns hospitals
i got a problem with that you know what
i'm saying
like what i'm saying was like what are
you like but who should own the
hospitals
what i'm saying see to me that's what
that's where it gets shaky i know but to
me i
like the hospitals then you're not no
but i feel like the health i feel like
but
then you gotta then you gotta have [ __ ]
government run and then it'll be like
the post office and that [ __ ] would suck
yeah i do you know anything about lausa
i know this is the worst run [ __ ] i i
get that i get that
i can give a better education in this in
this room than la usd can give
to someone in high school listen i get
that yeah but at the same time though
i think it's like i think that the the
medical care should pay for itself i've
always said this it's like it's like
when you get a cat scan right
and they say you get the bill and it's
six thousand dollars why
yeah what was it you got the machine
this would be like me you already paid
off the machine machine pay for it
this would be like like you know that
machine is paid
they'd be like if you're trying to like
heat up food in my microwave and i
charge you fifty dollars every time like
why they were your paper
this what what's the [ __ ] so so okay so
the argument then is
somebody had to pay for it right
somebody has to pay but what i'm saying
who incurs the cost of people
what i'm saying is this [ __ ] i'm saying
what is the cost right
you what i'm saying is like this should
be one of those things it dictates
yeah yeah what's the cost well it's kind
of like it's like when sag calls me and
they go you owe this much money i go why
yeah what's that money for yeah okay but
if they tell me no no but here's the
thing see now that's different yeah
because it goes to the union it goes to
the healthcare
they could they can run down the list
and go here's what the money goes to
some because i've asked them but now we
know what this money goes towards in
hospitals
right so this guy's pocket [ __ ]
yeah so i go what
yeah like i don't want to hear about
anybody that can't get insulin
i don't want to hear about anybody no
yeah these things can give people a cat
scan
one thing i liked about have you ever
been to the facebook campus they call it
you know
oh man i went to if man it's incredible
i've been to google
it's incredible you go to facebook and
they're like you know all the food's
free
you know yeah that's what google is like
and they got a hospital on
campus right because it's like yeah they
pay for it and
like you work there you just go right
you know what i mean so what i'm saying
is like
is is there a way to have the medical
system be like that because
to know that like getting rich off of
health care i just have a problem with
that well what about well see that
this is this is hard because like what
about what about what about doctors and
dentists like should they get rich by
doing what they do check this out
this check this out like a dent like a
dentist you're not saving lives check
check it out should you be a millionaire
yeah why not what i'm saying is what i'm
saying is
what's the line what's the dividing you
know what i'm saying it's like the
people that actually do the work
yeah yeah yeah just [ __ ] oh oh
does he work at the front desk like if
he's checking people in
but think about it more like this he's
in real estate think about it like that
he
he's not banking on like the hospital's
profit itself
the hospital is profiting and that goes
to an even larger thing but like
he owns the building like like that's he
doesn't if
he doesn't make money because saint
john's makes money he makes money
because that property is worth money i
know but
so who owns the property i know but it's
like should that be that
shouldn't that be like eminent domain or
like i don't even know if there's no
i just don't first of all if we get into
that maybe i'm a bleeding heart about
this type of thing
yeah i just have a problem with i have a
problem with pharmaceutical companies
well that's bigger than me
like that should be like that's more of
an issue
no sense no that [ __ ] that's the one
thing i agreed with trump on by the way
yeah trump was talking about that he was
like you know insulin should be like
water
you know [ __ ] i'm making it as cheap as
water this is gonna be tremendous
you know like that kind of stuff i go
yeah i agree with him on that
he said a lot of [ __ ] that i was like
okay good i'm glad he's doing that
somebody's saying something
you know but yeah i just feel like the
fact that like
you know but anyways it goes back circle
back around to like what's happening
with
with this it's like you know money is a
factor in how we determine everything
so you just go like you're saying like
why is target open
you know they could do all delivery if
they wanted to they can have all their
but then but then like we don't care
about those workers
right we don't care about the people
that show up amazon had 32 000 people
get sick
amazon and everybody's like but i still
need my [ __ ] in my front door that's my
point is like stay at home also the
amazon workers are all getting sick and
the ups drivers the fedex drivers
all are getting sick however you get to
stay at home so it's like
rich people get to sacrifice other
people's lives for their enjoyment
that's my point well that's the
hypocrisy of it
that's real but also
[Laughter]
i came over here to get some money we
get paid for this right oh my god
come on man i need some money we've put
a price on health care that is
false it's fake but it's not us that's
fake it was given to us no i know but
it's like
whatever that cost is it's fake it's not
real yeah it's some it's an arbitrary
number but i think everyone should be
able to get health care it should be
very affordable and reasonable
but i think completely free is a it's a
flawed system it's the same way i think
about
education for free that's bonkers that's
by the way like who's paying for i know
but that's another one that i don't
think should be for profit
so education yeah it should be
affordable but it should be
for them you have to pay for some
somebody has to pay for the things to
expect no but for the most part i
i i feel like the money that goes into
education goes back to the education
you know yeah yeah you know yeah but i
just think
that that's what that's my thing about
free health care when they're like
totally free health care you're like
the reason it would be so hard is
because there's so much that goes into a
system
that to just say it should be free it
just doesn't work listen i'm not saying
it should be free
but i don't think somebody should have
10 billion dollars from healthcare
no i agree but see i agree with that and
i also think it shouldn't cost a million
dollars to go get health care help
i think it should be unbelievably
affordable yeah i just yes
i think it should be remarkably enough
i'm saying i feel like
just take the profit out of it all
together and the money should evolve
you know should flow through to help you
know yeah we make sure our doctors are
tiered paid and they get you know
whatever it is i i don't know our system
is cracked is the problem and the reason
i say like people
doctors should get paid like senators
you know yeah well
you know you i don't think senators
should get paid [ __ ] they should i think
they should work regular jobs that
should be their side gig you know
like a [ __ ] uh he's a butcher you got
to get some meat from him and you go hey
uh take what
uh what's your can you fix the there's a
street light on
we'll look into it i do i do think
there's a lot of i think government
governments are scammed i feel like
teachers you know the people that do
those types of
types of jobs i mean i just feel like
could there be a way i don't have the
answer
we don't know what i'm saying there's
like there could be a way that the money
can
flow through itself because i'm just
merely pointing out sometimes i go
when they say something costs my
question is why
well show me the show show me why it
cost us and that's what i agree because
they can't they won't be able to show
you on the books no because they'll be
like well it's just
this and you go okay well show me the
line because i guarantee you
the line is going to end up at such a
such
person or company yeah and then you look
at their profit you go so then
this is just to make them rich right
it's not because this costs anything
well
i'll give you the other side of the
story not to stick on health care
because look i don't know everything i
just know you're the only one
i just know what i just [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's a podcast but like look at look at
like i have friends that are veterans
and when they go to va hospitals which
are government-run
and they're free for veterans you can't
you can't hear enough complaints about
the va
no i know but this because when the
government does run something as a whole
it's going to ruin it so my point is
without private without private
enterprise who's gonna run these things
okay
because i'm not trusting the government
for [ __ ] they suck they [ __ ] up
everything you said the dmv the post
office
lausd bro simple [ __ ] like so they can't
even do
that those are big things i'm talking
locally they [ __ ] up like
small [ __ ] look albert and look how
we're [ __ ] up our response to covet
right so how can we trust them to do
[ __ ] anything yeah so
i don't think the answer should be you
make a you're a billionaire because you
own hospitals but i certainly don't want
to be
hand the keys over to the [ __ ] morons
down in city hall yeah
those guys are [ __ ] idiots they don't
know as much as you do they don't as
little as we know
that that that whole thing the problem i
have is
when people were screaming defund the
police um and i understand what the
rhetoric meant what it meant was
reallocate funds it didn't mean take the
money all the way from there's no cops
it was just a dumb
that's a dumb slogan it was a terrible
slogan you know what i mean that's just
a terrible story reallocate funds makes
more sense but
it's like my defund bad friends i i had
that
no but it's a catchy defund the police
is catchy i get it but also
when you say if you really said if if
somehow it was communicated that
spend the money better everyone would go
yeah spend the [ __ ] money better yeah
you see what i'm saying is like it's
communicated incorrectly that's why
these wars when people go
you can't take away the cops it's like
they're not asking to take away the
[ __ ] cop
they're saying why do i have 19 tanks in
marina del rey why do the cops have
like i say there's money that was wasted
because the government once again
wastes insane amounts of money yeah we
need 19
tanks why yeah why well it's just like
get the [ __ ] army resort or get the
national guard in here are you talking
about a school
i remember at a time and i don't know if
these numbers were correct or not
but there was a time that it said it was
costing
like to send a kid to school you know
like to like it was like it was ten
thousand per
student yeah per kid yeah but you can go
to a private school
where the tuition is like 5 000 and
probably get a better education
sure so again when it just comes to the
government and how they allocate their
funds
you know what this is this is on all
levels just you know that's just my
common sense
view of and i think that that's like to
bring it all full circle of all the
things we're talking about is like
that's really what we're talking about
so like you know it's like
you're not you're you you're not an
anti-covert person or
you know or you think it's false or
you're one of these people that's like
i don't want to wear masks or or one of
these people that's like
everybody should stay inside and stay
away from everyone there's some kind of
middle ground
that is there that has to do with like
how things are governed
how we make the choices who makes those
choices and why
right you know when they were talking
about opening up disneyland i was like
if they opened up disneyland they did
right they did no no no no
but they were trying to like the next
thing is gonna be theme parks and i was
like i can't go do comedy in a parking
lot
but [ __ ] donald duck can run around
hey yeah you know like
that's when you go don't tell me that
you care about health and safety there's
something else going on it's money it's
always but this is this is the root of
all this
and the bottom line is there's so much
gray area
that's why that's why i like to say i'm
a centrist i genuinely mean that because
i don't believe everything the left says
and i certainly don't believe everything
the right says
and i think if more people had a more
centered view and go let's look at all
of the factors
right yeah because everything is gray
every there's no there's no
nothing has ever been cut and dry
nuanced is the word i like to use
yeah it is it's nuanced there's no way
to just go this is always going to be
the right answer and that's always going
to be the right way
they need it's case by it's everything
is case by case like me
i have antibodies and i get tested
regularly still for the tv show
when we had when we had um a case
infection on set which happens all the
time now when you're shooting
they make everything shut down and the
our net our health advisor
called us and she called me personally
and she was like hey you were in contact
with someone coven
you don't have to um quarantine because
you are
in the antibody window so i didn't have
to quarantine right it's
case by [ __ ] case check this out so
so you she can't say that though
wait wait let me ask you this don't you
get a sense
that okay because because look at the
nba in the nfl
yeah right yeah so the nba goes all
right uh
sunshine's got covet they can't play
tonight they got to move away durant
they don't they don't shut the nba down
no so don't you get a sense that even
like in hollywood they want to go
they kind of want to go all right
somebody got covet so they're gone
uh we're gonna move on with other things
but they can't do that
especially in hollywood because the
optics because it's more
i think they're making choices based off
optics yeah not
off actual data and facts right
gavin newsom i mean this motherfucker's
like shut down l.a he's out eating at
french laundry having [ __ ]
arctic char and behind closed doors it's
like they're all doing things
they're all saying that the right thing
because it looks like it is the right
choice but they're breaking the laws
themselves
so it's like i don't know why the
hollywood doesn't take over like like a
show like like i don't know why they
don't take over like hotel convention
centers right
so like like let's say like dave you
know they they find like a
you know a hilton that's got a big
whatever they put the set there make
that the stage make that the sound well
for us we shoot on location and then you
stay
in the hotel oh right right right you
know what i mean like they can make
bubbles
it depends on what you're shooting yeah
i know that's hard we're on location for
shows that are on stages they're having
an easier time
because they are on stages at universal
and mourners but like we're on location
we have no stage we shoot in los angeles
so well they're just making like i know
the nba has protocols now they're not
doing a bubble they they
i'm sure secretly they have like some
rules and regulations that the nba
players have to follow they do
you know just in the same way they can't
go skiing you know because it's in their
contract you can't go ski because if you
broke your leg
well they're not paying you 10 million
dollars they say you can then your
contract is very
confident so they they've had they got
together and they're like all right
here's the covet protocols you have to
follow
if you don't follow these things you'll
be fined or you can't play
so i'm just saying it's like what i'm
saying is
shouldn't that be how society is run of
course you know shouldn't it be like
okay we have to make sure but it's just
hard to govern that well because again
because everybody's selfish again
everybody has their own self-esteem when
the government is involved again there's
too many [ __ ] things to go through
bureaucracy is a nightmare when when one
job can be done by one person but
they have 17 people on the job they're
all going to want to keep their job so
they're going to make trouble just to
keep their job right
and and it's and it takes 17 times
longer to get something done because it
has to go through all these channels
that's what the government is to me
that's why i don't like government
intervention and everything
because you're like these [ __ ]
can't get [ __ ] done they can't get [ __ ]
done
so we entrust these people to do simple
things
like this on a local scale right on a
small local scale in parts of los
angeles the
[ __ ] the guy who's running business
in santa monica and venice
and and you know ventura county
right it's like how come these all are
on their own scale we they should all be
they should all be viewed
and and broken down as what is how can
we make this work the best way possible
instead of like shut it down [ __ ] it but
last last thing on kobe because like
because people
i know people are gonna be saying
already in the messages more political
talk it's like
ain't political talk we're just talking
this is what's going on in the world by
the way we don't know anything that
we're talking about yeah yeah
i made up literally everything right
speculating that's what we do
why can't we why can't we're having a
conversation that you would have with
your friends but you're just watching
our conversation so
this isn't just you know whatever take
none of it seriously
yeah but here's my here's my the thing
that makes me ask this is the question i
have that again i would want to ask a
scientist
okay so you take florida
this motherfucker's been open they don't
carry the whole time right that's not my
point
they've been open the whole time
california closed for most of the time
right
so you would think based off of what
they're saying about that they'd have
more deaths
that florida would have a hundred
thousand deaths and it would be just
this thing
how come it seems the same let's
actually now that you say that because
i've had this conversation
like i'm just wondering like even at a
place like there's a place like
my our but we have uh a married couple
that we
we hang out with you know and uh
rachel's friend you know
and they just went to idaho they went to
a restaurant indoors
you know yeah you go so i want to know
so all the places that are
indoors is there percentage of people
worse there than california
because if it's not i have to ask the
question
what are we doing so here data table
this is covidcdc.gov this is cdc website
uh
you know which you know this is the best
you can do it's at this point
this is data table for average cases uh
daily per 100
000 people arizona's number one
california oklahoma rhode island
arkansas new york utah georgia tennessee
kentucky massachusetts south carolina
new jersey north carolina
alabama lose nevada connecticut west
virginia indiana kansas delaware
mississippi texas
texas has been wide open they're way
down on the list okay new york and then
florida
listen listen that was new york city in
new york city you know what so they're
way down there wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait but how much time
let me let me come to the other side now
because this is the thing i hear
because this is the thing i'm going to
hear from like just like
the progressive aggressive liberal
people
yeah this is what they say the first
thing that comes out of their mouth
florida's lying
florida's lying about their numbers
florida's not telling you the truth so
if you believe that then we could be
lying about our numbers then we can't
have an
argument with anyone well yeah because
when you say you're lying also by the
way on the contrary on the
on the opposite side of that spectrum if
they're lying about how little we could
be lying about how how many we have yeah
exactly so if that's your
if your argument is you're lying then
it's like okay well then they're lying
to you everybody's lying so my point is
this right all right so here's just a
just
common sense person i'm not a scientist
yeah you know i went to some college
you know what i mean i didn't go i went
to four years of
barely a college yeah but you still you
know i went to listen i went to usc
and i didn't finish i went to westeros i
went to west la college and then i
transferred to usc
i didn't finish i started work and then
i became a comic okay they came here
like you know and here i am you know
what i mean so yeah so i guess somebody
already tweeted to me like
all i said was i didn't think donald
trump was qualified to be
the president that's then the guy was
like what about your education
[ __ ] i ain't running for office
never neither one of us qualifies right
right right
so anyway it doesn't it whatever that's
either here or there but i'm saying it's
like so as just a person that's like a
human being
a member of society if i can't gather
information other than like you say you
go to the cdc website
so i go to this if i'm just a regular
dude and i go well let me see what's
going on
and i see that florida's 15th on the
list and they've been open this whole
time
i can't ask the question as a
californian
why what the [ __ ] i know what are you
doing that's my point
what are we doing because that's my
point it's like because it's so vague if
it's going to be the same number of
deaths this is what i'm saying
can we just be wide open like like other
places
wearing masks keeping our distance
eating outside can we do that
and still have the same numbers if
that's the case why aren't we doing that
right if you're telling me well we can't
do that because it'll
triple quadruple explain it to me but it
didn't because it because it doesn't
seem like that's the case but
because other places that have large
populations like texas and florida
they're per percentage and per capita
it's the same
i know that's why i don't understand i
don't understand it that's why we need
someone to we need someone with a brain
for the brain to explain someone with a
brain please come back
to both of us and here's the other one
if you have them on your podcast please
have me come here i will i will because
i'll come
just to ask questions well because i
also feel like look and my opinions on
all these things everything we've spoken
about may change depending on time
yeah so it's just like i'm not set in
stone about anything i feel about
anything
i just but you want you want new answers
as time goes on because
something i thought five years ago
doesn't apply now something i thought
three months ago doesn't apply now you
know yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
like well you know what you know that's
why people are like they put you in
categories because you say something and
you believe in something no i know i
like i'm just trying to figure it out
just like you're trying to figure out
but what i think the trouble that people
have remember when you used to tell me
that obama's a terrorist griff used to
say that [ __ ] all the time
[ __ ] but i think people have a problem
with me
i think people i just think in general
like especially people that listen to
podcasts or watch them
they hear a buzzword they hear a
sentence yeah and then they fixate on
that yeah and now they say
you're like this without listening it's
amazing that we even
that this country even runs with so many
like [ __ ]
congress senate it's so many different
it really doesn't though
it's great it's actually amazing but you
know in closing you know about
all of this all this i can't believe we
went down this road no no
it is what it is you know what let's
make a promise to ourselves
the next time you come online the next
time i come on yours yeah we won't talk
about all silly yeah it'll be joking
okay we could we could be dumb like you
know
yeah yeah we'll pretend like we're
fighting you'll make asian jokes at me
[Laughter]
you know what uh you guys are your
[ __ ] fake ass podcast slot for you
i have a slot for you no but listen you
come on and take over
but listen here's my guest here's here's
the thing here's the thing it's like
you know the the
the if we could just
find a way to just if people could just
listen to each other just calmly talk
about
things yeah just have a discussion about
like the different sides and just like
find a way to agree to disagree you know
it would be fine
i mean because one of the things i would
say that has come out of this even in
the bad stuff like today i was looking
at
the the the vote against trump you know
the the thing impeachment yeah
and you know what it was the first time
that it actually gave me a little
hope and remember that the constitution
is a great document
yeah you know because no matter what
even if you have people
who are like this election was stolen
and it just
strongly like far right
you know the constitution is like eh and
even these people that are far
left the constitution is like yeah slow
down yeah it's nice
you know and i kind of feel like even
with all this happening because i was
starting to think like damn
is it going to be civil war is there
going to be like you know you start
those kind of things creep in and then
like the system of government and the
constitution steps in
and and people that uphold it like even
somebody like if you hate mike pence
because there are people that like think
he's a racist and people hate him and
he don't like gays right he's one of
these like crazy
staunch christian types that think like
you know gays are bad
whatever but but at the core of him he
believes he's a good person
sure you know what i mean and i think
that i think he believes more in the
constitution and the government
than he does in christianity by the way
that's just my i think they're one and
the same to some of those guys
okay but i like to hear that he was like
now i'm not gonna just
do what you want me to do because that's
not what the constitution says
it tells me that that oh wow you know
we're okay well he's more dignified for
sure than his counterpart i mean
he's more of an adult by the way he's
more of a savvy politician too yeah he
is but he's all
more of an adult that's like look i'm
sure behind closed doors mike pence poor
mike pence
at some degree is like there's been a
[ __ ] nightmare we lost
this is [ __ ] up we need to get the
[ __ ] out of here when
else would you you know you know what
you're like the mike pence of bad
friends
and he's trump as long as he's trump no
but
as long as bobby's trump mike pence what
i'm saying is no matter what you have to
deal with
yeah you get a chance to do this great
thing and you know you know what i mean
like
like why would mike pence turn that down
like he
never would have had a chance to be vice
president never like
he wouldn't like his political stances
and stuff
no one would like he was like oh [ __ ]
i'm gonna be i'm one away from the best
job in the country
i don't care who it is so i get the
intoxication of that power well yeah and
wanted to do that but anyway my point is
i just think that you know after
everything that has happened for the
country still to be like all right we're
going to bounce back here's biden coming
into office and
you know even if he doesn't work out
we'll keep going
you know i think there's something to be
said about we would know
that america is a great place you know
and yeah it's [ __ ] great
even through all this if you're a person
that supports trump if you think
you know we we're we're better for it
then you we we're in a place where
all different sides can come
and we could still get [ __ ] done yeah we
could still live and coexist and we
could still
you know what i mean yeah we know we
haven't done this properly but i just
feel like
i think it's a it's a good thing all
this all not
i think it's just a good thing how the
constitution
is handling yeah all of this stuff and i
think we should have some hope
for the future after we get through the
hard times and then we come back up
because we're gonna have good times
we're going to have bad times
but we stay constant because there are
other places in the world where you
you don't have the same freedoms yeah
they stone people to death
for their their their sexual proclivity
yeah i mean whenever somebody's like
america sucks i'm like go live somewhere
where they [ __ ]
can they cut your [ __ ] hand off yeah
go go live in europe where they throw
bananas at black players at soccer
matches
today yeah why can't we do that here i
don't understand
no they can they do it in boston yeah
they still do boston's not a part of
america i know
boston is europe they're the closest
that's where they went first
those people are still there that's why
that's why they still do that [ __ ]
[ __ ] had a tea party right
there
so it's like so anyway my point is still
a great country it's still a great
country it's like you know
are we sexist yes i think we're more
sexist than racist i've always said i've
always thought that
the last election proved that you know
but we look we're still racist
like you know we're still we're there's
still some racism and there's still
issues involved look at the
discrepancies and what's happening right
now it's clear and present right
you know we're still we we have these
issues but don't act like
it's hunky-dory in [ __ ] ecuador you
know [ __ ]
or like poland or like wherever they
just let women drive in saudi arabia
[ __ ] three years ago for the first
time like what the [ __ ] are we talking
about
what are we saying right now you know
what i mean so anyways and by the way
they shouldn't be driving here either
no that's insane it's the same i make
that joke and someone said oh you think
he believes that yes i'm in the car with
rachel the other day
yeah you know she got the gps on and
still get lost where are we going
yeah should we get gps's on i go you
just passed
oh you know when you're in the car
funny story about rachel real quick
let's just tell one funny story about
each of our loved ones okay
we're walking down the street over here
we get to this we're gonna
get some takeout you know and there's
like
there's a sign for help wanted and there
is a poll blocking the words
and rachel goes oh look they're looking
for
they're looking for what does she say um
you know no the uh a
wait what was it a cook with
experience you know yeah i said
experienced cook wanted right
so that's what it said but rachel saw
and she goes
before she says she goes oh they want an
experimental cook
maybe they do maybe they're like we
usually make japanese but if you want to
come in with she goes
oh look experimental cook wanted i
should go apply for that
and i was like experimental because like
what restaurant i look
then i go go rachel
experienced was she mad
and she was so mad at me we laughed like
we were like she was laughing that's
good she was laughing so hard because it
was like it was just so
cause then she thought to herself yeah
that would be ridiculous why would they
want an experimental
i don't know man times are getting
[ __ ] weird out there i think they
might want someone to mix it up
yeah so rachel wants to like now she's
like she keeps going live on instagram
she wants she wants her own sting so i'm
going to start riffing with rachel
oh my god this is how it ends
this is how it ends i'm warning you now
bro
and the wives when the wives get a
podcast it's over i know
that's the new that's that's the i mean
can i tell you something huh
good i hope she does and i hope it takes
off takes off
because i'm just gonna be the person
behind there going like good job buddy
good job baby
you know switching good you're doing
good you know i want to be a
stay-at-home dad yeah i'm trying to
convince my wife to get only fans i'm
like get on there let's go man you saw
what some of these girls are making
what's her name made two million bucks
in a day what bella thorne and the
bellathorn
is that it bellathorn yeah she made two
millionaires two million bucks in one
[ __ ] day
i listen i'm old school we're not the
same age but we're close enough where
you're probably from this era
where hookers
because they're hookers we call them
prostitutes okay prostitutes hookers
call girls
yeah it was shady it was frowned upon
yeah
because for me it was street walking
people that's what it used to always be
that's what you know you see you know if
they got
the advent of the internet they got a
pimp and so when you that it has this
negative connotation
because i come from that era right you
know what i mean right and so now this
new era of like
prostitution is just it's it's different
but it's show not touch
it's it's it's it's it's eyeball
prostitute but it still comes with
you know some negativity and all that
kind of stuff yeah but look what i'm
saying to you is that
i actually don't have the same like
negative feeling about it anymore yeah
because well because because
could you just go okay good for you
because what you see from monetize your
monetize your monetize them titties yeah
monetize yourself because i'm doing the
same thing i'm monetizing my personality
i totally i
monetize those nipples i'm genuinely
into it we talked about the other day a
teacher is in trouble
online a teacher got in trouble for
being on only fans it's like uh
what are you mad at this girl about yeah
you pick are you playing yeah it's on
her own time
first of all which is total and it's
totally legal right what she's doing is
legal and it's on her own time
so this teacher can't make money off her
titties you're paying her 27 grand a
year what the [ __ ] you think she's gonna
do to pay rent
well i put her in a position where it's
almost like they put them in a position
where they some people have to do these
things to survive right well on the
other side of that though
my pushback on that for the other side
is just to be like
okay cool but yeah this is this is we
don't want your
students to be able to find you like
that and we don't want that in a thing
so what i'm saying is if you make it so
much money go do that you don't need to
be a teacher anymore
right at some point when you are you
know if you are making a lot of money
yeah i'm just i'm just saying i imagine
they're not making a lot of money
they're probably making just enough to
pay rent not everybody's making a lot of
money that's what i'm saying so a lot of
people are just doing these things to
get by but the article was like
you know the article was trying to [ __ ]
on
the the hate of it they hate people that
are haters which i thought was good it's
like this is one of those things where
the the the liberal ideas of it
i agree with this whole like body
positivity or female empowerment i'm
like hell yeah let this girl go get
[ __ ] paid on the internet showing off
her body if she feels like it because
it's
she's not being forced right she's not
got a pimp that's making her do things
if she physically on her own time as an
adult person wants to set up an adult
site and have other adults pay for it
i got zero beef with it and get your
[ __ ] money get your money yeah i'm on
that page
get your money what i don't actually
understand is like all these
dumb and dumb and i'm i'm saying it
all you dummies who are just giving away
for free
like dude you go on instagram right now
you go on reels
right and maybe because i follow rachel
i mean honestly maybe because i was
looking at too many
so now that's all i see yeah bro the
amount
of 18 to 25 year old women
in bikinis doing sexy [ __ ] on the inside
on
instagram on instagram yeah it is insane
i'm talking about you could just do like
this
yeah for 30 minutes go to your explore
page and it's just you know
oh my titties and i just go wow you know
you can get paid for that
right yeah like like you're not
monetizing this so
i i just it blows my mind yeah i don't
understand it i also think it's i also
it blows my mind what are we supposed to
do like
and then they don't think they they do
they know who's looking at it
do they think do they understand like i
don't know if you understand
young female out there and
actually young males too this is both
you know what i mean because i'm sure
there's you know
it's the same thing everybody's
objectified do you understand that
everyone is looking at this yeah anybody
people you know people people that you
don't want look at how the algorithm
works
if it's like you're in a category of
just young
chick in bikini so if one weirdo
me
they're all seeing it like it's just
i i i sometimes i look at this like oh i
don't get this
yeah this is where i feel old because i
don't it's not old it's just
it's that's just the reality of the time
now i mean it's amazing like they used
to blame magazines before
remember how you would blame magazines
and tv shows you're giving young women
the false you know you're giving young
women the false this is what beauty is
right you know who's doing it now you
[ __ ] yeah them
you're doing it now who are you gonna
blame right who are you gonna blame now
are you gonna is it the tv shows that
are no no no it's the young girls who
just
open up their phone and go oh look at
these thousand
chicks who are my age and they're all
beautiful
and i want to look like this that's what
i'm saying somebody's like blame that
don't blame entertainment anymore some
when somebody's like they blame men for
body image issues with women i'm like oh
really who do you think runs
cosmo who do you think runs all these
these female publication websites that
put up all these pictures of women
it's women women are the people that are
dictating what other women should look
and feel like it ain't men
maybe that was 50 60 years ago but let
me tell you something any sort of female
lead driven publication
that talks about women's bodies good or
bad fat or skinny
it's all women that's all no guy no guy
right now runs a a sight
uh uh uh uh judging women's bodies
probably saying this is what you should
look like where you shouldn't
women are doing that themselves they're
putting themselves in categories and
going
just like uh amy schumer got in trouble
with or got in a thing with um
alec baldwin's fake foreign wife hilaria
baldwin whose name is hillary and she's
from boston and she's like i'm from
spain and they're like
you're from boston she lied he was like
what are you talking about
uh people from high school were like
what that's hillary
um but like they had a tiff online
because she showed her body after she
had
given baby giving birth and she was
quite skinny and amy schumer had said
some [ __ ] on there like
this is my point there's a snake eating
their own tail amy who's also like very
feminist forward very
you know what i mean she's out there
saying like this isn't what most moms
look like after
giving birth because she's referring to
herself that she didn't lose a lot of
weight but it's like
then she got clapped on for people were
like that's really [ __ ] up to like
say that because her body is different
than yours and she feels healthy that
way that she's wrong and amy apologized
probably they had to take it down and
then
they publicly hash it out but it's like
that's the snake eating its own tail
yeah yeah when you go after your when
when you keep making all these arbitrary
things
you can't say this you can't say that
you can't say that you can't say that at
some point
you're you're you yourself are going to
say one of the things you can't say and
you're gonna eat your own [ __ ] tail
yeah good luck
good luck that goes back to all the
things i was saying about twitter and
all that [ __ ]
the more you band the more we restrict
not donald trump
the idea of banning restricting and
changing and shaping and cutting off
corners
we are we are all going to put ourselves
back into a corner of going
[ __ ] i i guess i also uh one time
made a a a joke with a racial epithet
and i didn't mean it like
and the it's the end of times that will
be the end of times
i know man it's uh it's uh that being
said we should end this episode by both
yelling the n word as loud as we can
no i'll say honky and you
this is just not a good word for you
white people honky yeah that's not a
cracker means nothing to you
i mean you you uh douchebag is is it
just
it means nothing it doesn't make you
feel anything it doesn't make you like
you know
there's no word that we have that people
called us redneck nothing that
woodpecker nothing
yeah that's [ __ ] wood those are funny
things it's just funny yeah
well there's no words nothing biting
like the good old m word huh but then
the n-word's been
been taken back by black culture and
used for its own for its own
even still though even still which only
perpetuates to other people going like
you say it bubble but it's just
yeah yeah yeah yeah so what do you say
don't say it any people shouldn't say it
anymore
at this point i just go at a certain
point like maybe we just remove it
because
you know can't yeah because who cares
you know because
yeah you can't if you can't remove it
because it just
it's it's there yeah you can't just like
you know okay we can't we don't say a
word but if they can remove anything
they would they wouldn't just remove the
word they just removed black people
[Laughter]
we can only hope what you're saying
you're so stupid so dumb
so dumb no more black people that's what
i want
more black people on this earth less
whites oh
that's already happening they're already
talking about the browning of the world
because good more mix
more mix you know what that makes me a
minority and i get more roles again
here we go here we go
the guy on a tv show right now talking
about he wants more roles
i do want more roles who doesn't let me
ask last
this isn't closing yeah isn't it funny
when you look on i don't even know if we
even talked about this already but you
know when you look at a tv commercial
now
um and you see like black dude
with the with the asian y for the white
wife is she my eye roll
it's like it's like something they're
funny that's your first thought of like
what y'all doing but you know why you
know why
do you want to know why it's like cowboy
man because they're all
reaching so hard to try to be woke when
they only care about dollars anyway
so they're appealing to this nominal
idea
of like oh there are people that that
date out of their race of course there
are
but when they show it we know it's
[ __ ] you know i mean like it's
disingenuous
but you know like are there people that
that date out of their race of course
millions but when they do it because
they're selling a toyota
senior senate you know it's [ __ ]
you're like this is [ __ ]
but you did this because you thought it
was the right thing to do it's gonna
take a long time to get that sentiment
out of our heads unfortunately
and that sentiment was created because
for so long we would look at tv
and it was just all all white
well it's just mostly white or if it was
all black it was an all black
and it wasn't all asian families
and then even that we would look at like
oh we know what they're doing there
yeah you know what i mean oh the black
the black shows are on everybody the
black show
i remember when i was a kid my my my
friend my buddy maurice
i'll never forget him and his mom
maurice white guy white guy anymore no i
know right
this is this is i'm gonna say this
because this is like how she would say
it
i'd be sitting there as a little kid you
know and she would see wheel of fortune
right and she would go like this [ __ ]
on wheel of fortune
there's a [ __ ] and she and then the
whole house would come running in whoa
let's see what's going on so it was like
that's the thing
it was like that's a great sketch by the
way it was like this
really like moment and i never forget it
as a kid i'll never
i loved his mom his mom was a bad
[ __ ] i remember one time
i i was in the store and i walked in the
store with my friends and
him and my friends and i had a soda you
know
and i i walked in with the soda and they
wouldn't let me take the soda out
because they claimed i stole it
[Music]
but she took me down to the store she
was pissed and she
went off on everybody and i was standing
right behind her like i was back there
like this uh huh i told you i didn't
and like and all i saw was like she was
like it was a
it was the stereo stereotypical black
mom black mom
stuff like like whatever you would see
on tv right this was it was it right
there
she got my she got my soda and i walked
out of there like
[ __ ] she goes and now we're stealing
this one to go
[ __ ] you know what i mean so i just i
just feel like
again my point about it is the fact that
back in the day
like we've been inundated with
television
is supposed to look like this right
families are supposed to look like this
so when we see something odd we feel
like ooh
should that black guy be with that white
woman and this because of
they did it themselves right these
hollywood liberals they've done it
themselves and now they're trying to
reverse the course
yeah and we're looking at it like it's
not like hollywood was run by
republicans
i know what you're doing well but but
but it's like because it wasn't run by
republicans for 40 and now it's liberal
they always were the same it's just
it's just the truth is they realized the
snake ate its own tail yeah they went so
far
so now we call the [ __ ] do i ever
see a commercial
i saw it yesterday so it was like a
red-headed white guy with a black wife
and it is the toyota suv and they take
the two half kids
to [ __ ] uh uh you know like a lake or
whatever
and i know what they're doing and i
don't immediately go
why is that why i deal with that but no
i just know this
they think this is earning them cookies
right but it's fake
does that family exist of course it
exists one of my
one of my best friends he's black his
wife is white their kids are mixed
i don't ever think about it any other
way than i that's my family that's my
friends
but because i know that the corporate
interest for them
is about making sure you see that then i
go
this is because you want to say you're
cool with it we all should be cool with
it it's like [ __ ]
we were cool with them by the way they
shouldn't allow red hats to get with
black we're fine
[Laughter]
because those kids are oh that's
probably how you were born [ __ ]
it's like
[Laughter]
okay blake you heard it come get this
[ __ ] see this [ __ ] right
here
handsome that dude is by the way i know
i know i'm just i'm just teasing but you
know
but you know it's a lot of weird okay
we'll see
we'll see what bill burr's kids look
like and i know that probably i'm gonna
i'm gonna tell him that what are you
doing what do you have a kink kinky red
hair
is just that's not a good one no yes it
is bro stop hating on my [ __ ] people
[ __ ] racist [ __ ] see this is
racist too
uh that's the one time i'm gonna be
full-on racist you racist [ __ ] i
know there's some kinky redhead right
now watching like
how dare you right dad am i wrong
i'm gonna have my uh don't listen to
that half breeze i'm gonna go i'm gonna
tell my wife if i can i can have a baby
with a black woman just a rub just rub
it in your [ __ ] face
i'm gonna make you babies you and rachel
baby listen i'm already worried about
that kid
like he's redheaded and he's black get
him it's still i'm still iffy about you
two having kids
but anyway fine fine me too listen you
can find andrew on whiskey ginger every
week and yes
every friday of course that abomination
of a podcast bad friends
bad friends on mondays on mondays you
got uh dave which is coming out again
very funny that's a great show and you
can still see i'm dying up here on
is it on so you can still see it oh yeah
go check it out come on haven't you seen
those little checks we get uh
that that show still i'll take some more
residuals yeah so that's still on so
check that out
uh special is the special still on i
don't know i hope not don't go find that
just go watch uh just go watch
dave when it watch down on fx and watch
bad friends and whiskey ginger and and
this dude's gonna come back
whiskey ginger when you come back will
you have a drink with me or no no
dude i'm not gonna do that please i'm
gonna know dude come on your fan the
fans want to see you get lit
nope i was with griffin you are you
gonna burn christchurch
no don't even what are you talking about
make you take your shirt off yeah yeah
yeah take my shirt off and give me your
birthday was that when you had a drink
when we made you have a drink
oh that was my uh whatever i don't know
what it was 48
no no no 45 45 that i don't know what it
was a
pina colada is that what yeah it was
some kind of no no it was one of those
like brown drinks
you liked it though i didn't you said it
was all right it was
yeah i was like okay but that it's not
like i was like oh
[ __ ] what have i been missing no i know
yeah we got a make we got the main line
boosting you somehow what we need to do
is like go on a vacation
i would love that that's what we need to
do yeah we'll get the ladies let's go
let's
let's go it's dead seriously yeah that's
what i'm about to do that's the kind of
stuff exactly
and you'll do it down there yeah i would
i would do it there you know what i mean
i would do it like i would be like you
guys heard it i would i'll i'll try
because i did that before i went on a
vacation and that's the first time i was
like i'll try a full-on
thing and i hated everything yeah like i
had a
i had a banana colada and i was like
they ruined this good-ass shake
with rum with this bitter ass who peed
in this this is how i felt about it
so so so i just need to find the right
we'll get you we'll get you the good mix
i didn't need the right mix but anyways
there's been another episode of riffing
with griffin
and again my my good friend uh my dear
brother here mr andrew santino and i
will see you guys
next week
you